I swear. Um, I got to do the episode where I'm just doing ads.
That's going to be that episode's going to rip just to get so respectful on you
guys to just do add 60 minutes straight up of ads.
And just in a, in no shirt.
Drinking a Virgin, my tie, I don't, you know what that is? I just heard, uh,
heard about them. What's a, uh,
what's the other one where you put the leaves in it. What's that one called?
Is that my tie? What's the one that girls drink. Mohito dude.
Remember when girls figured out that thing, like four years ago,
they were just like, wait, there's the mojitos. And then there,
they went nuts. Wait, this is how you,
you know why it's such a girl drink because you can put so many things in it.
Do you know what girls love things? Girls love things.
They say straight up.
You know what guys, guys like, I don't know guys, guys.
I dunno, whatever guys, like, guess what guys, like whatever.
This is what girls love things, dude, if you could hold the thing, forget it,
dude.
Get it. Chotchkies you should see how many.
Times [inaudible] my mom has. How much has chotchkies sounds something like,
it sounds like it's a racist thing. Is it? Probably I have no idea.
I have no idea. All I know are chotchkies are things. And if it's racist,
come get me babies. I've got no clue. Uh,
do it.
My mom's got so many chotchkies and then she's got the nerve when she's done
with the tchotchkes to be like, Hey.
Chris, I got some stuff for you. Come put this church key in your house.
I got a whole closet full of chotchkies. Cause of my mom. Life's hard.
But what I'm saying is girls love things and that's why my ties kick.
Give a girl. Oh, you don't think girls love things. Dude.
Give your girl a bag full of in it. Give your girl a bag full of it.
things in it. Watch her smile, dude. She'll get chapped lips.
You smile so hard. So smart. So hard. That,
that on the bottom of the middle of her lip just goes.
And then all of a sudden she's like,
I need chapstick and you go check the bag because it's in there because it's a
thing.
That's why girls have chapstick. They don't even like it.
I like to always keep my lip. No, no you don't. You like it. Cause it's a thing.
That's what girls say. Let's fix it up. It's an old car.
It's so you get the car and what do we need? The parts and oh, we have good.
We have this stuff. Let's not fix up the car. I just really wanted all the.
I'm surprised girls. Aren't hip to those glasses that come up like this yet.
They just like the real big ones. Cause it's more of a thing.
But you mark my words. Girls are going to be wearing those.
In.
By next summer. I'll ah, you know what? By the end of this summer,
I'm gonna put.
It out there. Girls are gonna be wearing those flip-up glasses.
That Corey Haim used to wear. I swear to God, because it's the thing,
because they've got two things now they got this part and this part
it's amazing how much girls love things and they do.
And that's not a sexist thing. It's a gatherer thing. A hunter gatherer thing,
guys go out and get the things and they bring the things to the girl and the
girls put it all in the house.
Wonder what the girl is, who got the first thing was probably some,
uh, uh, a, uh, a big
bunch of tied ups. It's weird.
How that's yeah. A bunch of tied up sticks. And then they were like, oh,
you can burn this. And it makes a cool scent. And the guy was like,
what are you doing with that thing? I, you know,
it's usually for firewood and he's like, no, no. She's like, no,
it's for smelling. And he's like, that's not a football.
We mean like it makes the hut smell. Good. All right.
Okay. Jewelry. There you go. Bam.
What'll guys wear a tie. Or if guys don't want to guys are like,
I don't wanna wear the tie with a tie.
You see a guy who doesn't wear a tie, wear a tie. You see his face, bro.
Have you ever seen a guy's face? Who doesn't usually wear a tie wearing a tie?
It sucks. GOs. Love to get dressed up though. Let's do it.
I mean, not every girl, you know, but I'm saying girls are like, I mean,
weddings girls are always like, yeah, we got to go to the wedding guys. I got,
I got to go to North Dakota.
It's so DIC for anyone to get married for real. Nah,
it's not Dick to get married. It's so Dick to have a wedding
guide when guys are like, yeah, sorry bro. Like I get married. You got guy,
you got com. Where is it? Hawaii. Yeah. I guess. No, no,
that'd be a good one. Where is it? Oh, it's in Michigan dude. What? Yeah.
Her family is from Kalamazoo. So we're going to have it over there.
So 90 people are going to have to go over there that don't want to
sell. Yeah.
So I'm going to make all of my family go to Kalamazoo
because you know why? Because girls like things.
That's how much girls, like things they'll make you what a Kalamazoo,
because of how much they like things.
So you got to go and you got to dance the night away. Dude.
You gotta dance the night away and you've got to trick yourself into, ah,
you know what? This is? Yeah, yeah. I had a good time. I didn't want to go.
But I got there once I got there, it was he ever talked to that guy.
That has to do it. A real man goes like, yo,
did you have fun though? Was it fun? A real man goes like this. Nope.
Didn't to go.
Was there made the best of it because I'm a human being and didn't want to
have to jump, but it was fine.
Cause I made it fine in my head all from a girl
because she loves things.
And you know what makes the world go round things?
Yeah, man, I always thought about how girls,
like things ever since I was a little kid, I would be like,
goes like things I'd think about that.
What a weird kid. I must have been mad for real.